a Tennessee man sent back to prison
after his sentence was reduced by
mistake is expected to file for clemency
Matthew Charles was released in 2016
after spending 21 years in prison but a
March a judge ordered him to return to
prison and finish the rest of his
35-year sentence the push for his
release comes as President Trump
commuted the life sentence of Alice
Johnson a nonviolent drug offender
Charles's case has been the subject of
tweets from Chelsea Clinton and Kim
kardashian-west tarika Duncan is
following this story jurika good morning
good morning we talked about how rare
this is after nearly two years of living
as a free man Matthew Charles is waking
up in a County Jail in Kentucky he is
waiting to be moved to a federal prison
where he will face another decade behind
bars while legally Charles should have
never been released in 2016 those close
to the father of two say he's already
done his time you let someone out you
give them their freedom and then you
just take it back that's just grossly
unfair John Harrison said goodbye to his
longtime friend Matthew Charles at this
April going-away party in Nashville
Charles is now behind bars a place the
51 year old knows all too well in 1996
Charles was sentenced to 35 years in
prison in part for selling crack cocaine
he served 21 years with no disciplinary
infractions during Charles's time in
prison President Obama signed the Fair
Sentencing Act lowering sentencing
guidelines for crack cocaine offenses
Charles appealed for a reduced sentence
and was released in 2016
Harrison says Charles came out a
reformed man reconnecting with his
family attending church and volunteering
at a soup kitchen he got a job he got a
vehicle he got a rap place to stay so he
was really kind of getting his life back
on track but in March a Tennessee judge
ordered Charles back to prison to finish
his sentence as it turned out I was
wrong
former judge kevin sharp reduced charles
a sentence in 2016 sharp says he made
his decision based off an incomplete
record that failed
Oh Charles as a career criminal based on
the record in front of me I would have
made the same decision but the record I
had was incomplete though career
criminals are not eligible for reduced
sentencing sharp beliefs Charles should
be free he has done sufficient time
based on the crimes that he committed
it's I believe it's time to not release
him but a May 30th filing by the
Tennessee Attorney General cites
Charles's past drug convictions along
with convictions of domestic assault
kidnapping and shooting a man in the
head the filing also claims his 2016
sentence was unlawfully reduced he's not
necessarily the poster child for you
know someone that you would think of
rehabilitating him so the fact that he
got out for two years and showed that he
was safe is unusual and that doesn't
count for anything according to the law
according to the law it doesn't matter
former federal prosecutor Michael
cornacchia says Charles's case is an
anomaly do you think there's any fear
that releasing someone early and they
commit another crime then it looks bad
on the Justice Department look anytime
someone's released after a lot of years
for committing crimes of violence
there's always that concern that they
may recommit a crime but the longer
they're in the the studies show they're
the less likely they are to resume a
life of crime it kind of shakes Mike my
trust in the in the justice system on
Harrison's friendship with Charles dates
back more than two decades they were
prison cellmates in the 90s Hairston got
out in 2001 and the pair have kept in
touch through dozens of emails and
letters May 11th 2015
Don praise the Lord brother all is well
with me I'm spending time in God's Word
and exercising every day Hairston says
Charles called him from jail a few days
ago I think it's harder this time
because he's been out he's done well he
didn't do anything to merit going back
before turning himself in last month
Charles told National Public Radio why
he still believes in Redemption
I didn't do it
your start is awesome to say Charles has
been a good point
let's give him a break here's a man
who's changed some see the changes that
he's made and others morning look at the
changes but that doesn't mean that I'm
gonna change back you don't know I'm
continually about this new life it's a
great life
an attorney for Matthew Charles told us
the commutation of Alice Johnson greatly
encouraged him in a statement after
Johnson's commutation yesterday
Charles's attorney said like Alice
Matthew Charles has also proven worthy
of a second chance obviously this case
different from miss Johnson because he
did have more of a past violent past but
the big difference here is he was
released he experienced freedom for
nearly two years it's good that we are
talking about what the changes and
transformations that people go through
in prison the important part of the
conversation Jericka thank you for that